this video is brought to you by squarespace
whether it's your new profession or just
a lifelong passion start your journey to
website glory with squarespace jack out there
awesome all in one platform through the link in
the description below more on them in just a bit
in all the long centuries that england has been
a monarchy some really terrible people have ended
up wearing the crown it makes sense any system
as old as that is bound to produce a few lemons
multiple kings have been deposed by their subjects
one charles the first was so hated that he had his
head chopped off and the monarchy itself was
abolished for over a decade with so many bad
examples to choose from it's difficult to settle
on just who was worst but serious consideration
must be given to the man that wore the crown
of england at the beginning of the 13th century
a man that presided over a large and prosperous
empire and promptly ruined all of it in a truly
spectacular fashion king john was never supposed
to have been king at all and his unsuitability
for the position was quickly made apparent by
well everything he did he had all the cruelty
of his predecessors but none of their skill
on the battlefield little of their cunning
and absolutely no inclination towards leadership
of his subjects he was the worst of all things a
character so cartoonishly villainous that he ended
up serving a fictitious role as the natural foil
of that most celebrated of english folk heroes
robin hood he was so bad at ruling england that
eventually his people rose up in revolt against
him and he died in the midst of a bloody civil war
that was entirely his own making this is the
true story of a man who almost single-handedly
destroyed an entire kingdom a man with so few
redeeming qualities that even the relatively
scarce positive steps taken during his reign
were done in an attempt to bring him to heal
john was born on christmas eve 1166 at the royal
palace in oxford his father king henry ii had
ruled over england for a decade at that time
and was in the process of building an empire
that included not only england but most of wales
and ireland and the entire western half of france
initially no one really paid any
attention to john since he had three
older brothers his chances of inheriting
the english crown or indeed any significant
land holdings were very slim as a boy john was
seen as king henry's favorite child though even
he didn't think highly of his future prospects
he jokingly referred to his son as john lachlan
a bad thing to be known by in a society where how
much land you control directly correlated to how
powerful and important you were the problem it
seemed was that henry had too many sons the king
had planned for his empire to be split up when he
died to be divided by princes harry richard and
jeffrey this left nothing for jon giving any land
to him would involve taking it away from one of
his brothers something none of them were willing
to countenance indeed the familial squabbles over
the vast empire led to a number of armed conflicts
between father and sons in the last two decades of
henry's reign it was after one of these conflicts
that john's mother eleanor of aquitaine was
imprisoned by her husband where she would remain
until his death jon became much more important
following the sudden deaths of first prince henry
in 1183 and then prince geoffrey in 1186 leaving
only john and henry's second son richard who
was now the heir to the throne henry used john
to try and control richard seemingly threatening
to make jon his heir instead of richard in order
to get him to do what he wanted richard chafed at
this and finally snapped in 1189 allying himself
with the king of france philip ii against his
father henry was ill by then a bleeding ulcer
was slowly killing him and the broken old king was
forced to capitulate the final straw it seemed was
finding out that his favorite son john had
decided it was in his best interest to side with
his brother in the conflict in the middle ages
familial loyalty counted for little when power
and wealth were on the line but even by the
standards of the day it was a stunning betrayal
though anyone that knew john personally wouldn't
have been surprised extreme self-centeredness was
already a well-established personality
trait in the prince at the time
henry died soon after making peace with his son
and richard was crowned in september 1189. before
he even became king richard's dearest ambition
was to embark upon a crusade to the holy land
the egyptian sultan saladin had captured jerusalem
from the frankish crusader states in 1187
and richard wanted to reclaim it for christianity
it was to be a massive pan-european effort with
richard being joined by king philip of france
as well as the holy roman emperor frederick
barbarossa richard raised vast sums of money
through the sale of royal lands and officers as
well as taxes to raise an army and equip it but
equally important was to make sure his kingdom
didn't fall into chaos while he was gone richard
set up a regency government to run england while
he was gone and named his four-year-old nephew
arthur of brittany the son of his late brother
jeffrey as his heir if anything happened
to him it's notable here that richard took
pains to ensure his brother john wasn't
a part of the governance of the kingdom
it was obvious that he didn't trust him not to try
and seize the crown for himself while he was gone
instead richard tried to buy john off by giving
him vast lands and extracting a promise from him
not to visit england for the next three years
richard left for the third crusade and things went
reasonably well for him he never made it to
jerusalem but he captured the strategic cities
of jaffa and accra for the crusade estates and
also agreed to a peace deal with saladin that
allowed christian pilgrims to visit the holy sites
in jerusalem unmolested at home however things
were falling apart richard's regency government
collapsed into inviting between factions and
john inserted himself into the mess to try and
take power for himself exactly what he promised
his brother he wouldn't do richard had made
enemies from sicily to cyprus during his crusade
and alienated his allies in france and the holy
roman empire which quickly came back to haunt
him philip returned home before ridge and quickly
became an implacable enemy allying himself with
john to sow chaos in england richard hearing of
the disaster unfolding at home left the holy land
but was shipwrecked on the way he tried to take a
land route home through germany but was recognized
and captured by the new holy roman emperor who
imprisoned him a massive ransom was agreed to on
the crippled richards empire financially for years
to come and richard returned home john's civil war
collapsed once richard came back to england and
he was forced to grovel at his brother's feet for
forgiveness it was obvious that richard held john
in contempt and didn't view him as a threat to his
power since he forgave his 27 year old brother's
actions as those of an ill-advised child john was
stripped of most of his lands and exiled to
normandy richard spent the remainder of his
reign campaigning in france fighting to restore
the lands lost to philip while he was on crusade
richard was perhaps one of the best warrior kings
england had ever had he was a talented general and
a fierce warrior gaining the epithet the lionheart
for his achievements on the battlefield but the
titular king of england spent very little time
on the island itself and never got around to
fulfilling his kingly duty of producing an heir
to his throne when he died in battle in 1199 his
vast domains were thrown into chaos and speaking
of domains perhaps you want to own one the online
variety that isn't if you're looking to build a
new website there's no better place to start than
with our friends over at squarespace now more than
ever people are getting creative with their time
they're reaching deep into their savings accounts
to start a new business or launch a blog to share
their opinions with friends and neighbors the
world is yours and squarespace is the perfect web
tool to help you fashion it into whatever you like
it's the platform to use when you're ready to get
started on our next web project that you've been
thinking about are you looking to get in and out
quick without thinking too much about what your
website should look like well bam use one of their
quick beautiful templates to make a website that's
fresh and for you like it's right out of the box
or maybe you're more of a hands-on person you've
got lots of opinions and ideas about what exactly
your site should look like well squarespace
gives you all of the customization options
you could ever want with no updates no patches
no technical bs to worry about once you're done
setting up your website tinkering with the design
if you're so inclined or maybe just playing around
with the colors there are so many extra features
that squarespace provides that your website can
thrive email campaigns patronage portals social
integrations membrane areas analytics commercial
options 24 7 customer support everything you could
ever want in one place so when you're ready to get
started on the next web project it's got to be
with squarespace go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch your site
go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics
to save 10 of your first purchase of a website
or a domain and let's get back to king john
richard's sudden death left two possible heirs to
the english throne along with the vast territories
in france that the crown held john as richard's
brother and author of brittany richard's nephew
richard hadn't designated a successor before
he died and the law of the period was confused
and unclear making conflict inevitable much of
the english norman ability supported john who
was crowned king westminster abbey while nobles
from brittany angel and maine supported arthur
so did king philip of france who saw a weakened
england as strengthening his own position
initially john saw success in the war against
philip and arthur he was able to defend his
position in normandy from phillips forces while
scoring a surprise victory over arthur's forces
at the battle of mirabeau on the 1st of august
1202 capturing arthur and almost all of the rebel
leadership but all that he had gained he promptly
squandered through his own personal shortcomings
government in the middle ages revolved around
the king but no king could run his government
effectively without support from the nobles and
john seemed incapable of getting along with his
the king routinely alienated angered and ignored
advice from the nobles no matter how close they
were to him or how powerful they were added
to this was john's pension for cruelty that
was considered excessive even by the standards
at the time the nobles he captured at mirabeau
were imprisoned in such deplorable conditions
that many of them died offending and angering
their surviving relatives then jon shocked all
of europe when in 1203 he murdered his 16 year
old nephew arthur after a drinking binge throwing
the boy's body in the river more and more french
nobles turned away from jon and allied themselves
with philip who was on the offensive in normandy
by the end of 1204 the entire duchy which had
belonged to english monarchs since the days of
william the conqueror was now entirely in phillips
hands the french king followed up on his success
in normandy by seizing anjo and poito as well
suddenly and spectacularly john had lost almost
all of his continental possessions that his father
and brother had captured and offended for decades
the dramatic loss of normandy would dominate
john's politics for the remainder of his reign
the king desperately wanted to regain the lost
territory not only because he considered it his
birthright but also because the inability
to hold it was a personal humiliation for
him and the country he led the problem was war
in the middle ages was expensive perhaps even
more so in relative terms than it is today
since standing armies didn't exist at the
time any proposed french invasion would involve
raising and equipping a large body of troops as
well as securing naval vessels to transport them
across the english channel further complicating
matters was that in this era it was a lot easier
to defend territory than it was to capture it the
landscape was dotted with castles that dominated
the surrounding area which could be garrisoned
and provisioned to withstand months of siege an
attacking force would steadily be whittled down
by the elements by disease by battle wounds and
that was even before dealing with the possibility
of a relief army that could march out to meet them
in a pitched battle all of this meant that once
normandy had fallen to king philip it was going
to be very very difficult to get it back all of
this might have been overcome had england been led
by a charismatic leader or at least a brilliant
military commander henry ii might have been able
to do it or richard the first but john wasn't his
father or his brother he was only a marginal
soldier at best competent but not brilliant in
the field as for charisma he seemed to possess the
exact opposite of that people were repelled by him
especially the nobles few of england's barons
didn't gain anything by a campaign in normandy
hardly any of them owned land in france in fact
they were increasingly jealous of the expatriate
french nobles who'd been displaced by the war
and had assumed positions of power in john's
court they felt that since normandy had never been
part of england in the first place merely ruled
jointly by the same monarch that they shouldn't
have to spend their treasure or their blood
trying to get it back especially not on behalf
of a king they were growing to despise john for
his part despised the noble's right back he was
exceptionally paranoid that any of them might
grow powerful enough to challenge him he attempted
to squeeze them for the money he needed to conduct
campaigns in normandy through any means he could
come up with taxes levied on noblemen by john
included scottish a cash payment made to avoid
mandatory military service inheritance taxes on
lands castles and noble titles import and export
levies on goods shipped through english ports even
forcing widowed women to pay a tax to the crown
to avoid being forcibly remarried these levies
combined to put much of the english nobility
deeply in debt to the crown which jon then used to
control them his favorites could have their debts
forgiven while those who displeased him could be
deprived of their lands and their titles john's
eye for money didn't just fall on the nobles
either he also sold royal officers including
sheriffs to the highest bidder he established
import and export fees on goods shipped through
english ports england's population of jews which
were permitted to live and do business in
the country only at the pleasure of the king
were heavily taxed a common practice when monarchs
found themselves short of cash you'd think that
with all of this money flowing in king john
would be able to seize back his lost territory
in spite of the reluctance of his nobles to
follow him into war ah if only it was that easy
in 1214 king john must have been feeling pretty
confident he was on campaign in france at the
head of an army that had captured much of anjou
and was still making moves towards the french
capital paris after several failed attempts
in the previous 10 years it seemed that he
was on the verge of gaining back his lost
territory and then disaster struck john's
campaign hinged on an alliance with the other
major player in european politics at the time
otto iv the holy roman emperor otto had invaded
france from the north while jon was in the south
planning to trap king philip and his son louie in
a pincer movement philippinoto met each other at
the bridge bevin not far from the city of lille
on the modern day french belgium border it was a
fierce battle for by heavily armored soldiers
hacking each other with swords maces and axes
typical for the high middle ages after hours
of fighting the critical moment came when the
french king and the german emperor clashed in
the center of the field with their retinues
with both men nearly being killed and having
horses killed from underneath them after nearly
being captured by the french knights otto was
forced to flee the battlefield his deputies the
counts of flanders and bologna were not so lucky
and were taken prisoner the imperial army had been
decisively defeated the loss at bouvoin spelled
the end of john's ambitions in france left without
allies he was forced to sue for peace and once
again dejectedly returned to england empty-handed
by now things were really reaching a breaking
point the nobles of england were on the precipice
of rebellion the discontent between john and
his subjects had been building for years john's
oppressive taxes were making life difficult for
more and more people commoner and noble alike the
fact that all of this money was being squandered
on campaigns against the french king that failed
to accomplish anything just made things worse
there were also serious questions being raised
about jon's behavior while it was expected for
wealthy men at the time to keep mistresses it
was considered unacceptable for those mistresses
to include married noble women something jon is
known to have done several times for that matter
his wife isabella of all joules might have been
as young as nine years old when she was married to
the king in 1199 and had already been betrothed to
another nobleman hugh of lucinor neither of which
apparently bothered john that much he treated most
of his nobles with outright contempt preferring
the company of his toadies the new man that he
entrusted to help him run the government instead
of the land in ability and in a move that had
serious political and social consequences he had
embarked on a dispute with pope innocent iii that
had ended with his excommunication in 1209. the
pope also put the entirety of england under papal
interdict which forbade the saying of mass inside
any church in the country at a time when almost
all of society revolved around the church this
was a serious blow the two had reconciled in 1213
but the experience still haunted the pious kingdom
wide and served to turn the majority of england's
clergy against the king with so many enemies and
so few friends rebellion was probably inevitable
it finally flared up in the aftermath of john's
failed campaign in france in 1214. a great
coalition of barons from the north of england
banded together in april 1215 in the city of
northampton and at the head of a large body of men
marched south capturing the city of london john's
position was clearly untenable and in a last-ditch
effort to save his crown he sued for peace
the king met with his rebellious barons on the
15th of june 1215 ronnie meet 20 miles west to
london attempting to mediate between the two
was steven langton the archbishop of canterbury
the negotiations went beyond the individual
demands of the nobles and raised questions
about the way kingdoms were governed up to now
no real checks on the absolute power of kings to
do whatever they wanted existed either in england
or most anywhere in europe while english kings
swore an oath at their coronation to rule in
accordance with the laws and customs that already
existed in the kingdom there was no legal recourse
if a king simply chose not to do so it was a
fatal flaw when a bad king like king john came
along put the entire system at risk of collapse
in an attempt to rectify this what the
nobles wanted was a guarantee of their
rights and liberties under the law they wanted the
rights of the church to be respected by the king
protection from illegal imprisonment and a fair
justice system that they could appeal to what
they especially wanted was the establishments of
limits on the king's ability to tax his subjects
without their consent the two sides agreed to the
great charter or magna carta in latin on the 19th
of june the charter called for the creation of a
body of 25 nobles who were empowered to coerce jon
into complying with the terms of the charter they
would ensure that the king ruled not according to
his own personal whims but according to the law of
the land most historians consider the creation of
this legislative body to be the first english
parliament neither side really believed that
the peace agreement would hold for long this was
proved out when it defined john appealed to his
one-time adversary pope innocent for help as part
of john's peace agreement with the pope he agreed
to make england a papal vassal state and innocent
believed that the magna carta curtailed his own
rights as a feudal lord so he declared the charter
to be null and void it became clear to the barons
that if they wanted their rights guaranteed by law
they'd first have to earn them on the battlefield
the entire kingdom descended into civil war in
1215. hard-pressed by john the rebel barons turned
to france for help king philip proved reluctant
intervene in the chaos but his son prince louis
did not he invaded england at the head of a
french army of knights and mercenaries and
joined with the rebels at london
where they proclaimed him king
the barons had decided that they would
rather be ruled by a foreign king than
by john any longer despite being excommunicated
by the pope louis pressed the war against john
to a fever pitch plunging the entire kingdom into
anarchy and violence king john seemed to be at war
with everyone his barons the french the scottish
who took advantage of the chaos to invade northern
england still john had plenty of money saved from
his various taxation schemes enough to pay for a
sizeable royal army john would attempt to fight
all of his enemies at once rather than compromise
he was defiant to the last but in the midst of
this even his body betrayed him in september
1216 while long campaign john contracted
dysentery known at the time as the bloody flux
the same disease that killed john's brother
henry in 1183 and john grew gravely ill as well
likely dehydrated due to severe diarrhea in
october the king was no longer able to travel
he was at newark castle in nottinghamshire on
the 19th of october 1216 when he died at age 49.
one wonders how he might have felt as he laid
dying his once prosperous kingdom brought to ruin
his continental empire lost and england
overrun with foreign troops but really
he had no one to blame but himself his selfishness
his paranoia and his tyranny had brought all of
this misfortune upon him it would be left to
his successors to attempt to clean up his mess
john's death proved a turning point in the
war with prince louis most of the rebel
barons switched allegiances from louis to john's
nine-year-old son who was crowned king henry iii
louis suffered a string of defeats over the next
year that compelled him to return to france and
give up his claim to the english throne henry
would spend decades attempting to recapture the
lost territories in normandy with no more success
than his father had the loss of normandy marked
a turning point in european history the beginning
of the historic rivalry between england and france
that would reach its heights during the hundred
years war from now on kings of england would rule
from england instead of from france and over the
course of the next century english would supplant
french as the language spoken at the english
court but it would be the magna carta that would
prove to be the lasting legacy of john's reign the
failed peace treaty was revived by henry's regency
government as a framework for governing england
the charter would be reissued several times during
henry's long reign and his successors would either
rule according to its precepts or face resistance
from the nobles in particular from now on whenever
king wanted to levy attacks usually to fund a war
he needed to ask parliament for it thus giving the
nobles and later the commons a stake in running
the kingdom no one realized it at the time but the
great charter would prove to be the foundational
document for almost every democratic constitution
the world over not that john should receive any
credit for this of course the only reason the
magna carta was conceived in the first place
was because john was such a bad king that the
nobles wanted to prevent someone as bad as him
from running wild throughout england ever again
perhaps the greatest testament to how terrible
john's reign really was is demonstrated by the
royal family themselves over the course of the
centuries there have been eight kings named henry
six georges eight edwards even two elizabeths
but there has never been another king named john
in england great britain or the united kingdom
and who can blame them after all
who on earth would want to be known
as king john ii so i really hope you found
that video interesting if you did please do
smash that like button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for watching